There's no need for you, who can survive in extreme environments without protective gear, to
build such an extravagant facility.This
place is a
birdcage.They put human slaves and brats here and
used summoning magic to buy humans.
In order for a witch who is on the verge of extinction to be taught and fight, she
needs military power, which is why Chloe created it.
Only Chloe
can create a quill for you, so she wants to bring her back to life.The
magic is...  The witch's
soul says
it all the time.Wait, what are you planning to do?You should be
surprised to know that.I won't allow you to waste your life, so I'll bring you back to life.That doesn't
change,
that's all I'm going to do with her wishes.
But if Quest rejects you, the
witch
will be nothing more than an enemy.DET